in december 2019 one of the most
powerful men in the global car industry
jumped bail in japan while facing
charges of financial misconduct
and was smuggled out of the country in a
large box
for carlos gone who headed an automotive
alliance including nissan renault and
mitsubishi
it was a spectacular fall from grace but
saw his reputation trashed and a
mountain of criminal
and civil charges laid at his door
gone's flight from justice took him to
lebanon which has no extradition treaty
with japan
and he joins me this week from beirut
all along he's insisted he's innocent of
the charges against him
so why run away
[Music]
carlos gone welcome to conflict zone
thank you you seem to want your
reputation back
almost as much as you wanted your
freedom
given the multiple charges you still
face do you think you'll ever be fully
vindicated
well uh you know if you
have been following the so-called
justice system in japan which looks more
like a hostage
justice system i don't think you will
ever be cleared in japan because the
intention
from the beginning is to charge you the
question is
what is the charge is going to stick and
how long they can keep you in japan
unfortunately as you know
things did not turn the way they wanted
it
look at the trial taking place today
with greg kelly my ex-colleague
who has been held in japan now for two
years and a half
which trial i understood is going to
have a conclusion
by the end of this year which will make
him three years in japan
for a charge a single charge which is
complicity in non-declaring a
compensation that was neither
decided nor paid that
senator weaker chairman of the trade
committee
in the u.s senate called a bogus charge
so if you say when my name is going to
be cleared in japan i'm afraid
unless they really change the hostage
justice system
it will never be cleared but my battle
is not
for the japanese government or the
japanese prosecutor
or the executives
the the the the bunch of executive
organize the plot
but it doesn't help you does it mr
opinion it doesn't help you that
in the eyes of many people you're a
fugitive from justice aren't you
even though you say you'd never have got
justice in japan
and you were hardly treated my question
is are there any circumstances under
which you'd return
to japan to face trial yeah yeah i will
go to japan gladly to face trial
when there will be a justice system in
japan where
defense is allowed to express itself as
long as there is a joke of a justice
system
called the hostage justice system there
is no way i'm gonna
put myself in the masquerade justice
that i was submitted to for more than
one year
the japanese government has said it will
never give up fighting to get you back
and with an international arrest warrant
out in your name the world's going to be
a very
small place for you isn't it unless you
do return
how long can you live in this kind of
limbo
yeah well first obviously as long as you
have the hostage justice system i cannot
go to japan now for the other country
there is there are rules in the interpol
because you
you're talking about the red notice
which it
is implemented on me at the request of
the japanese government
there are rules and uh between the rules
of interpol just for your own knowledge
interpol cannot intervene if human
rights are being violated
interpol cannot intervene if it's a
political issue
interpol cannot intervene if the the
matter
that we're dealing with could be done
outside the justice system well uh as
you know
uh pro or if not i'm gonna tell you i
have the three
reasons for the red notice to be
eliminated
it's a political situation second my
uh human rights have been violated it's
not only me saying that is the united
nations
expert commission saying that and asking
japan
to do an investigation about that and
third
even the prime minister abe prime
minister ex-prime minister of japan
said this matter should not never have
been
landed into the justice system in japan
it should be
have been dealt with in the boardroom of
nissan
mr gohan you've complained bitterly
about japan's
justice system but you don't seem that
keen on the french
justice system either which is also
investigating you
you told a newspaper last month you were
no longer sure you'd get a fair hearing
in france either you sound very much
like someone who isn't going to accept
any justice system unless it finds you
innocent
is that right yeah the the french
investigation
came on a voluntary base i accepted to
answer their question
they came under the lebanese
jurisdiction
they asked hundreds of questions that i
was glad
to answer i would have liked this
interrogation to take place
a long time ago before the character
assassination campaign
took place not only in japan but also in
in france so i answer completely all the
question
and now we will see what's going to be
the follow-up
on this uh investigation but you've
criticized
you've criticized the french for
freezing some 30 million dollars of your
assets you called it
a method to weaken your defense why does
it weaken your defense maybe they're
just afraid that since you
jumped bail in japan you might move your
assets outside their reach
yeah exactly so yeah i criticized the
fact that they've been very quick
into freezing my assets which only uh
consequence is to make my defense
more difficult because obviously you
have a lot of bills to pay
that's what i've criticized as you know
in the japan on the japanese size my
assets have never been frozen
as long as i was in japan my bank
accounts were still open
i could make transaction easily japanese
never done this
but the french immediately jumped on the
first what they call
suspicion to freeze everything which i
consider
as one way to handicap my defense my
defense system these people i guess they
don't trust you isn't that the point
isn't that the point they don't trust
you well
this is th this is this is an old this
is an old story
you know the the reasons for which i was
arrested
in japan as as you know has nothing to
do with the so-called charges
they have been fabricating all the time
after my
arrest this is something which is linked
to a
fight inside the alliance and to the
conversion between reno and issa
you know if you want more information
you can read the book i have published
yeah i will come on to that in a little
while if we can a few weeks after your
arrest in 2018
you were allowed to talk to the press
which gave you a chance to protest your
innocence and claim that you were the
victim
as you say of an elaborate plot to
destroy your
reputation my question is why would your
enemies especially those at nissan
bother with a hugely complicated plot if
they didn't like the direction you were
taking the company they could have just
fired you
or got the board to fire you couldn't
they you've said yourself they didn't
need to go to all this
trouble to get you out uh sir i
if you consider that i was given the
chance to talk to the press
you're in bad faith you are bad faith
it's a bad faith
i've been denied any possibility to talk
and you know it
and if you ask a question that means
you're a bad face and if you were a bad
face we stop the discussion here
for one year for 14 months i was
forbidden to talk to my wife
i was forbidden to see my family when i
wanted to organize a press conference in
japan
i was re-arrested after i've been freed
a second time i was told
by the prosecutor that i'm free to talk
but there will
be free to bring new charges if you
consider that i was free to talk
frankly i consider that there you have
not
a minimum of good faith last last
november you told arab news
i knew very well that if the japanese no
longer okay we
will we will stop i'm sorry we'll stop
it here
and with that mr gohan left the studio
and refused our
invitation to return there are tough
questions to be answered
and we were looking forward to asking
them